The Fool in oppressor can see dad it
isn't at all you pray you mom you des
gamate Pirela they painted a parade
leave a Levitt take it easy
as they say in print when it comes to
environmental protection 24 year old
Shalini Fernandez has a long hot day
ahead of her
good morning I've come for the plastic
bottles
it's exchange day today so how's it
going is everything ready a lot of
bottles have piled up in her
grandmother's backyard every couple of
months it's time to get rid of them
there any more lying around we've got to
collect the whole lot the bottles are
valuable because they can be exchanged
how good was that aforethought
everybody wants the biosphere bottles it
really motivates the kids more than
anything they collect as many as they
can so you can hardly see any lying in
the streets now everyone wants to trade
in their bottles the lucky ones can hop
on board for a ride the most popular
means of getting around here anyway it's
busy at the collection site and stays
that way all day long the locals settle
in for an extended patient wait
fernanda's works for the biosphere
reserve and helps with accounting the
main cause of the glut of plastic
bottles is the palm oil used for cooking
here there's a collection in every
couple of months a total of 450,000
bottles have been collected so far 50
plastic bottles can be exchanged for one
made of stainless steel many of the
people who bring the plastic bottles
already have a collection of the metal
bottles at home I fill the bottle with
water so I have something to drink at
school what's your name sweetheart they
have to have exactly 50 bottles which
color would you like red or gold if you
bring me 10 more plastic bottles you'll
get another one okay we already have
four tons of plastic stored up on the
main island so to me a logistics company
is helping us tackle it
it takes the plastic tool is born free
of charge and to recycling companies
there are willing to deal with it all it
wasn't easy to find them no one was
willing to pick up the island nations
garbage the exchange program costs about
thirty thousand euros to run annually
and in a year it needs fresh funding but
plans are already in the pipeline we've
already ordered a machine which makes
plastic thread out of the bottles we can
work with it to make baskets and other
things it'll be super
my sibling Uplus Massey daddy
Panisse IPE is trying hard to be
environmentally sustainable it's a
constant balancing act the needs of
almost 8,000 inhabitants have to be
taken into account and so does
protecting one of the most important and
species rich forests in Africa the
island has been a UNESCO biosphere for
four years a status the Islanders
treasure most of them live from niche
agricultural products and tropical
fruits and cocoa a Portuguese colonial
legacy the economy here isn't
self-supporting a lot needs to be
imported which generates a lot of
garbage regional president Josiah dosa
Cassandra has ambitious plans he wants
to levy a stiff tax on all plastic bags
and bottles that come to principai we're
talking to the traders and telling them
change your ways use different packaging
glass or large metal containers things
that don't prevent us from becoming a
plastic free island or at least to
reduce the quantities over the long term
but what about the plastic washed up by
the sea the island invited Spanish
scientist mighty Ascencio to inspect its
beaches for micro plastic granules she
says most of the micro plastics get
deposited at the high tide mark she's
been doing these kinds of measurements
on the Canary Islands for a year it's an
easy and effective method it's mostly
organic is that good yes it's a good
sign the beach seems to be very clean
but some fibers can't be seen with the
naked eye some of it looks like hair but
it could be plastic it needs to be
analyzed analysis
and a low count in the sand doesn't
necessarily mean a low count at sea our
samples and Gran Canaria for instance
are full of micro plastics there's a
visible difference
everything that's organic material and
príncipe is plastic there it's a
disgrace there's no mass tourism here
and the locals want to keep it that way
but the island does need jobs and income
it hopes that 70% of príncipe trash is
organic the women compost it into
fertilizer a new cottage industry for
the island and new person Lanie
Fernandez also the compost piles have to
be turned over three times a week it's
hard work this is really bad it's
plastic the women say batteries are the
worst
if even one sneaks in it quickly poisons
the compost the women have been
specially trained in three months the
first batches of príncipe compost go on
sale they're already advertising with
farmers and hope they'll soon be reaping
their rewards value the work means a lot
to all of us we didn't have a job before
we're happy it gives our children a
future not a guarantee I'm a star you
know Sam's like and we're not going to
stand still we're determined to get
something going for the next generation
and there won't be much time for live a
levy until it's done
[Music]